Speaker 1: Okay. Today's Election Day,
2022. Republicans aren't even waiting.
They're already suing to get thousands
of mail in ballots thrown out. There's
a good Washington Post piece about this.
Republicans sue to disqualify thousands
of mail in ballots in swing states. The
lawsuits coincide with a systemic effort
by Republican leaders to persuade voters
to cast ballots in person and not absentee.
Critics are calling it a concerted attempt at
partizan voter suppression. Of course it is.
In Pennsylvania, we've talked about this before.
The state supreme court has agreed with the RNC.
Election officials should not count ballots on
which the voter neglected to write a date on
the outer envelope. Even if the ballots arrive
before Election Day. Thousands of ballots have
been set aside as a result, enough to swing a
close race. That could be a race right there
in Michigan. Christina, karamo, the Republican
nominee for secretary of state sued the top
election official in Detroit last month seeking
to toss absentee ballots not cast in person with
an ID, even though that runs contrary to state
requirements. Understand, that's not what the
requirements say must be done. When asked in
a court hearing, Karamo, his lawyer declined
to say why the suit is only targeting the city of
Detroit, a heavily Democratic majority black city,
and not the entire state. I wonder why. I wonder
why. And in Wisconsin, Republicans won a court
ruling that will prevent some mail in ballots
from being counted when the required witness
address is not complete. Look at some of the
things they've done this election cycle alone.
Continued gerrymandering based on the 2020 census.
Of course, that's the default. Some of it has
been has been blocked. Some of it has succeeded.
Eliminate polling places in minority neighborhoods
to create long lines so disproportionately
Democratic voters might say the lines too long.
I got to go because I have a life, I have a job, I
have kids, I have errands. Why make it illegal to
give people water when they are waiting in line?
Again, dissuade them from sticking around to vote,
but only do only try to have it enforced in
certain areas. Sued to stop mail in voting
altogether. Sue to have mail in ballots thrown
out as they were doing here. And then, of course,
as we saw in Arizona, have armed poll watchers
at polling places to intimidate, but only certain
polling places. It's not happening. You know, for
all of the conspiracy theories about secret cabals
and subterfuge that were not a way, you know,
all these different things. It's all happening
in the open. It's all happening in the open.
And so I hope that you were able to vote without
incident. After the break, we're going to talk
about a Trump lawyer admitting, oh, we're going
to claim fraud as soon as there's any delay in
getting results, which there will be because of
how the state laws are set up. But I hope you were
able to vote if you weren't if you had problems.
Email info at David Pakman dot com. And we will
highlight some of those stories if there are any.
Hopefully there aren't, but if there are any, we
will highlight some of those stories on tonight's
results stream. Make sure that you are subscribed
on YouTube and that you are following on Twitch or
Facebook. Those are the three platforms where we
will be streaming tonight starting at 730 Eastern.
The David Pakman Show Podcast. YouTube Channel.
Radio Show. TV Show. And Live streaming. All is
primarily funded by people in the audience. You
go to join Pacman dot com, you get a membership.
It's quick, it's easy and it's great.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where
you want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: We do a daily bonus
show. Alex Jones, who sells,
you know, other things, is furious about the fact
that what we offer is just extra content. That's
not a joke. That's not an Alex Jones impersonator.
That's really Alex Jones furious about the bonus
show. Get instant access to the bonus show, get
the commercial free audio and video feeds every
day. Get the invitations to the members only
live town halls with me and anger Alex Jones
by virtue of supporting progressive
independent media at Join Pacman
Dotcom. Today is the last day for the coupon
code. Big Voting 22. Today is the last day.